I wanted to motorboat my second grade
teacher
in hindsight you're still hot Mr Larson
Mr Larson she had kind of low-cut shirt
she was a young teacher she had nice
boobs and she loved to give hugs my
biggest dream was to put my face in her
boobs yeah do you still have the same
dream as an adult now I don't know what
she looks like probably hot I saw her at
a road trip that was really cool like
recently no no when I was a kid we were
like at a gas station and when I was
walking out I saw her her low-cut shirt
again she was with her rocker looking
boyfriend he looked like he was a part
of the Red Hot Chili Peppers
she knew what she was doing so stop
looking at
me